all right guys all right I guess you're
playing this game box in fright now I
heard it was good okay and a yes I'm not
gonna read everything they're saying cuz
you could see it you could hear it you
know it used to be a military base well
it used to be a ranching thing then it
was turned into an army thing then it
became a bird thing and a museum or
whatever Henry found a station here I
think for a bit unless he was Navy who's
Henry Fong but on Christmas time this
little breakfast place used to sell
these amazing polar bear sugar cookies
man those were good and then one year
they changed the formula or whatever and
ruined
Alex hey still with us you haven't said
anything for like 10 minutes yeah yeah
my my mind journal personhood not really
I just got in this morning and how did
her mom meet your dad exactly Amen on
vacation in Orlando he got lost in it
you know actually I'm not even gonna
tell this story it's really not worth it
no wait what happened I feel like I
haven't heard this he got lost in some
Gardens and he thought she worked there
and blah blah blah they hit it off ah
that's downright adorable and you guys
just met tonight yeah I was um I've been
out of school and the timing had just
never worked out so what does that make
you to her then yeah second cousin
he's my step-brother yeah I forgot that
uh who's that who's driving this that's
sea captain Karen she's doing us a favor
you'll notice we're the only ones doing
the voyage how you doing up there Karen
yeah what's up with that just no one
normally go there at night nobody really
lives there so no and Karen's not gonna
mind that we're spending the night well
at least you seem cool right
cool guy cool hat you get a cool new
sibling living right in your house
sharing your toothbrush yeah no it's a
hey there's an old ship's wheel up here
it's a replica from a Portuguese
Caravelle it says oh yeah yeah I think
the Portuguese discovered the island I
don't know I mostly slept with a
maritime portion of history class so how
do you two know each other
Oh way back when like Paleozoic grade
school era young enough that I've seen
her in a bathtub and it wasn't sexual at
all I mean we both look like little
skinned potato blobs oh so creepy now to
think about why we were babies it's
funny that's all
[Music]
check under your cities to make sure you
don't leave behind any grandchildren's
wait who's talking right now
it's a record they always play we should
get a quick picture this would be like
fine just hold the camera like five I
don't look my freshest right now it's
true Jonas this is like B - Alex just
for your calibration and it's Jonas not
Jonah yeah Jonas like Jonas Salk right
patient zero AIDS guy it's some
difficult right I think every names
biblical so probably here's good
come on Alex join the fun
they're great Oh magic erase all the
warts out and stuff so don't worry hey
Alex
you brought the radio right the little
portable one yeah of course
perfect can you pull it out a second
there's the little guy our high school
has a radio station and Carly she's a
friend of ours she's filling in because
Reggie got mono from some track runnin
or something it doesn't matter what
matters is that she's gonna say
something like basically right now about
our thing so tune it to 88.3 so I can
tell her we heard it which I played this
morning but oh oh actually it's a little
after 10 o'clock which means my dear
friend Ren and his buddies are probably
just touching down on Edwards island for
the yearly bash on the beach or whatever
we call it now but anyways I promised
him that I play a song from his band so
hope you're listening Ren here are the
redheaded bed-wetters with baby carrots
[Applause]
awesome
I hope Christina with her talent show
judge face was listening
we must be getting close there's no
radio reception on the island I'm glad I
got to hear it before it went totally
kaput if we can't use it
why'd you bring it not just for the boat
No you'll see
I don't expect too much but nah it'll be
fine
I won't undercook it you'll see smell
that clean air boys and girls
boy and girl this neat city living yeah
anybody need a smoke I have a full pack
oh no thanks I mean I literally just
said the clean air thing so Alex you can
bum one off me if you're empty yeah oh
no thanks I don't smoke last time I had
one that didn't go well yeah no I don't
know what coughing with your whole body
meant until I saw you dry heaving okay
just checking
all right my other friend should be up
and around the bay actually that I mean
I don't mean to be the guy to break us
up already but rent can you do me a
favor can I have like two real quick
minutes with Alex for a second Wow and
you can you know if you can run up and
meet your friends really just wait is
something
what is it nothing's wrong nothing's
wrong it'll just take two minutes
superfast all right but look I don't
want to go up by myself I mean can't we
just stick together you're gonna have
all night to say like whatever but since
you want to meet up with your friends
anyway going up ahead and we'll catch up
with you okay
I guess though this is a really strange
way to start off splitting up are gonna
be fast thanks man
I'll just be up the hill in case
whatever I get better Wren seems nice
he's funny you know yeah look just what
do you want to talk to me about before
suspect something nefarious
no it's nothing it's not bad listen I
just wanted to grab you ahead of time
and say you've been cool about
everything
and I guess it's just for me I've never
moved anywhere and like getting a new
family at the same time kind of feels
like I'm skipping the training wheels
not that it's been bad or anything you
and your mom have been great mom I do
Lemon's lemon-aid however that goes an
optimist Christ yeah I'm an optimist and
proud of it oh and thanks for setting up
the attic for me it's cool how it's like
a little bedroom I was in the basement
no problem anytime when the flag is
flying we are funning I think it's
supposed to say running oh we can catch
back up with Wren now I didn't mean to
take so long kind of kitschy
right it's kind of kitschy yeah it's
like quiche
I think they block this off at night
since nobody needs to use it or maybe
they just had a parade sure either one
if nobody lives here and the stores are
all closed whose car is this oh there's
always that one lonely car in every
parking lot
[Music]
ah god this was even here it's a
monument to some submarine that was sunk
off the coast oh do the the the radio
guide thing they talked about on the
boat you know it's what like 102.3 I
just want to see how it works
January 15 1941 and commissioned into
service at the end of that year under
the command of Lieutenant James Earle
clapping on October 28 1943 it was sunk
by the Japanese sub chaser toka sada
some 25 miles off the coast of
Washington and remains to this day the
only submarine casualty in American
waters eighty-five officers as well as
twelve army passengers were lost the
propeller was recovered in 1962 and in
1965 erected as a monument to the
heroism of the brave men and women who
tragically perished named after the
Hawaiian god of the sea the USS kick
parks and facilities office friends
sister Allison you stored there you'd
like her she's tall all right
man they closed them early I guess no
point in staying open if nobody's here
hello kids look the other guys and gals
must be further up so be quick now okay
speed redefinition of Edwards Island
this is a tourist trap with shops and a
beach nobody lives here except for some
geriatric named mrs. Adler but as God is
my witness
we'll never mention her or any other old
person's name again we are here to drink
and be stupid but tradition apparently
started by bored recruits in the 1950s
who had sneaked dates over from the
coastal towns they literally called it
trawling it's actually kind of funny the
beaten path officially ends here the
beaches past the fence I think Jerry
told me that there's a way that [ __ ]
huge we used to get over there but I'm
blanking on what it was but it's not I
mean it can't be too difficult Wow look
what
I mean Jerry got over yeah exactly so to
summarize we are not allowed here after
I think the dumpster will get us over if
it'll budge well let's try address
anyways the town's
youths keep the holes link over in camp
thing alive and well no no I am I got it
wait we're not allowed here after dark
so like what's her plan if we get caught
we won't I had to promise Karen I'd
shuffled her driveway all winners so she
just looked the other way and the other
thing is the weirdo caves weirdo caves
the whole reason Alex brought her radio
is because when you go to them it's like
the front the mouth the mouth of this
particular cave
you can sometimes pick up frequencies to
stations that don't exist
you'll hear voices or just it's um it's
pretty creepy
at least I've heard I did it once it's
amazing when it works so back up a
second who's mrs. Adler her family I
think like owns or owned some of the
island or something
she's been shacked in the same spot for
like 70 years she's kind of what you
call the local legend she owes I can't
imagine living in the same exact house
looking at the same exact walls for that
long a time well it takes a certain
someone and actually you know what
speaking of the opposite of those
certain someone's drumroll please
Jonas did you know that a little birdie
told me that our Alex here is thinking
of going out of state to college
oh really yeah and did this little
birdie tell everyone he did sue
Lyons even though it was only over the
pants stuff
[Music]
just because mark spent a study hall at
the advisory board doesn't mean he's
allowed to look through our submissions
look Alex I just if you are thinking of
leaving I just hope you're doing it for
the right fit yeah that's all that's my
whole spiel what the hell does that mean
nothing nothing nothing at all
do what you want forget I said anything
thank you
I will thanks so much for bringing me
out you guys I can tell I'm gonna have a
really good time
look I'm sorry we'll stop yeah this will
be fun don't worry even if alex is a
listless drifter ruining her own life
[Music]
[Music]
before we get there I should I should
probably mention that oh who's that
that's so there's this girl Nona
she's just this a girl and I'm totally
into her and I want her to be into me so
just you know just be cool okay no
pouting or complaining or anything all
right
Brandon relax Oh Jonas now that we're
dumpster buddies what was the thing that
you said Alex back there do you have one
of those vestigial tails or something
just leave it alone Wren all right you
don't have to hear everything I don't
have to hear everything but I want to
hear everything it's not a big deal
really
just Reginald I hear you over there hey
guys wait I was saying I was about to
tell the story what was it about Brad's
car
oh well vacuumed okay we started a fire
down the way but no no wanted to play
Beach nanny so yeah hi hi and Jonas that
are you Jonas that's Jonas he's Alex's
new in town fresh as a daisy stepbrother
that brother really yeah I know it's a
trip right yeah he's a cool guy from
cool North Valley so let's all try and
show them a good time just the beach and
some beer will be enough I'm sure wait
your Jonas Jonas the stepbrother yeah
what's your name again that is Clarissa
she's stepbrother like what does that
even mean oh my mom married his dad so
family law and all yeah well I guess
this is happening now
this is a thing that is happening so
where's everyone else
Nicole had that tennis thing and there's
nobody else coming wear it what
Clarissa we we took the last fairy I
thought more would show up oh my god
it's just Alex and her new stepbrother
huh that's it that's how you brought
that's the group oh come on Clarissa I'm
fun I'm hip I'm with it listen to
yourself wait aren't you all like
friends I'm friends with Nona and I'm
downgrading run to like a creepy
neighbor and you I just met yeah I'm
getting the picture now yeah fire man's
great equalizer so what's the what's the
like thing to do here other than
obviously go skinny-dipping and get
murdered by Jason Krueger yeah let's
just get drunk it's supposed to be a
party right hey where does that old
woman live oh you mean Maggie Adler ya
know where she's dead what yep killed
over three days ago was all over the
news local news anyway oldest living
resident her family's been moving back
and forth on the ferry getting all of
her crap hmm
sort of a bummer yeah well we all got to
go sometime
in her case later than sooner we need to
answer your previous question Jonas the
thing to do is lay on the beach and
drink till you can't remember where you
are sometimes play truth or slap yeah
let's play that we can inaugurate Jonas
truth or slap what's that we used to
call it hippo until we got tired of
people asking why is it called hippo
because you get to yell at your dirty
hippo before you slap someone you could
ask the question you have to tell the
truth but if somebody can prove that you
lied the accuser gets to slap you it's a
good getting to know somebody game ah
fun any excuse to hit run hey I'm the
truth is truth whoever all right get on
with it
okay so first ready uh-huh
come on fess up you want to go out with
no now right yeah Clarissa wait wait
wait I want to hear his answer oh man
you're good at this well if being good
means being kind of mean about it look
it's tough to gauge but something like
enough stalling I know you want to
sample the goods no I mean I I like her
as a friend right that's I just liked
her as a friend that's that's all she's
cool she's she's just a friend
oh yeah right okay thank you Karissa
what Alex come on what are you doing I
knew it you can practically smell it on
him can we just drop this please all
right Alex you get first blood and
slapping like you stole something I kept
it was just happening it's really that
much this is for your honor
watch and relish you've suffered enough
oh thanks so Alex's turn oh great here
we go
what's your favorite stuck there oh boy
yes mum this is pretty fun just watching
all the mates
someone were to ask you to describe me
what would you say about really swinging
for the fences here I tell them you were
an average girl with common thoughts
geez why don't you say I don't know what
I was expecting
so okay curses turn now Alex you got a
new brother pretty exciting I'm sure
Jonas is excited or maybe excited isn't
the right word
maybe a little overwhelmed with just
everything you know unsure it's a lot to
take in and adjust you I'm mom is there
like a question coming or what I'm just
saying what Jonas is already thinking
that statistics show if you get divorced
once you're probably gonna get divorced
again and the fact is your mom divorced
your dad so let's put his mind at ease
and here why I don't care sir Jonas is
fine
he's not a scared puppy none of that
matters well let's hear why your parents
got a divorce in the first place and
we'll see if it matters Clarissa I don't
really care why they got a divorce just
you know why Michael died and it broke
everything and they couldn't handle it
the end well now you know Jonas don't
die and everything will be fine okay
Clarissa what you guys honestly I think
I'm pretty much ready to do anything
else besides this game wait let's let's
not stop like this we should limes
overrun I won and to celebrate I'm gonna
sit on the beach and drink and maybe I'm
feeling spicy even take a nap maybe we
could that's exactly what Nona's gonna
do to man what is your problem Clarissa
just what did we what did I do to make
you act like I ate the last piece of
chocolate cake on your flippin birthday
nothing Alex you did absolutely nothing
cheese if you guys in your scavenger
hunt or playing ring-around-the-rosie
happen to find anything more interesting
than a slowly dying starfish you be sure
to just let me know super sure we'll
grab you if we find any island Bigfoots
Islands Bigfoot's exactly
well I want to inaugurate this [ __ ] by
checking out the caves no no want to
come uh
I mean away I'm very clingy run fine
Jonas you're a strapping young lad help
boost me over the fence the caves just
yonder and I guess you expect me to just
jump over after but like I said you're
strapping young lad okay come on I need
more bear where are you from again
it's a small town near North Valley oh
yeah is it nice if you like bars on the
windows
yes Alex she wanted to check out the
caves or uh in a sec okay yeah just let
me know thanks for making the fire yeah
sure
got it but those owl Scout wasn't Zeus
look no not now that we're not playing
that stupid game what do you really
think about Ren Oh what do you mean you
know as a boyfriend oh that look Alex
Rin seems nice and I know he's your
friend and you know whatever but I'm
just not in the mood for something right
now so if you could just like tell him
that just so he like doesn't get his
hopes up or whatever yeah sure thing
Thanks you look relaxed I am relaxed
Cloris is seriously what's your problem
nothing's wrong Alex and even if
something was wrong there is no problem
on the face of the earth that cannot be
solved by what I'm doing right now
what's that
staring into forever meditating yeah
sure
Island living huh uh yep
let's hop this thing and check in with
run all right let's do it come on I'll
push you over whenever you're ready
unless I get a crank in my back which
might happen if you don't go soon
so the cave
what's your bets on a scale of 1 to 10
how weird is it gonna be I don't know a
one runs pulled me into a closet to look
at a broom he swore looks like Abraham
Lincoln so adjust your expectations
accordingly huh
all right hey Chris it seems to be here
normal annoying self sorry about that
yeah what's her deal anyway I don't know
that woman's perpetually on her period
uh okay it's true kind of oh and what
the hell was up with you and the whole
Nona thing with the game I mean okay
fine fun is fun but I'm trying to get in
with this girl and it was as if you
liked making me look like an idiot
look run she told me to tell you that
she's not in the mood for a relationship
man I knew when Clarissa dug in that it
would screw the whole thing up with her
yeah this is so embarrassing it's not
about you it's nothing personal it's
just where her priorities are I guess
seriously forget about it yeah you're
right who cares
I'll get over it now who's ready to have
their minds bang if you don't mean that
literally
me me me oh wait actually I almost
forgot
gonna take a little magic trip to
cupcake town those look like brownies
brownie town yeah never mind that salon
run the last thing I want is to have to
chase your frailes screaming body into
the ocean because you want to pet a fish
or something what
Joanie's just gonna do it too right
Jonas Myka meet Asuka Mita uh no thanks
I'm with her on the whole not flipping
out drowning myself thing okay
delicious okay so see these little piles
of rocks the kids before us always leave
him here so you know where to try and
tune in the signals so you're gonna want
to stand basically right round here
and just tune the dial left or right
until you start hearing some weirdness
how will we know when it's you'll know
trust me so just pull out your radio any
day
[Music]
crap
wow it's even cooler than I thought it
would be what is it what's doing it
maybe the tunings like unblocking a
weather balloon or something it doesn't
make any sense
well it's just crazy then cuz I don't
know if you're over round it kind of
changes too I think like over at this
pile come over here and try it
this is so cool I know Clarissa and Nona
should see this right I mean I know it's
like weird with Uganda it sounds so yeah
it sounds not what I was gonna say but
what was that it's like this is gonna
sound stupid but there's like something
in here famous last words
famous no I see it too I'm sure there is
something in there like a giant rabies
filled back or maniac who wears a
mannequin vase come on or it kind of
looks like a pool or something like a
freshwater [ __ ] let's check it out
it's not that far in if it's a pool
that'd be cool I didn't mean that -
right cool
fortune favors the bold wait a minute
Jonas well I am going to just rest
against here because I think I think I
mismeasured the magic
ah we're happy zip Larson what a [ __ ]
[ __ ]
they're a [ __ ] benefit for them and
Jonas is pretty cool that's still a page
roasters Jonas where are you
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
there we go
[Music]
here
[Music]
[Music]
why would a guy bring an ashtray down
here or a pen
[Music]
see a man about a dog
sure are you alright
Jesus you scared me oh I scared you you
scared me I had no idea where you were
I'm sorry for going ahead I thought I
thought I heard somebody down here but
you know obviously there isn't but isn't
this place incredible I mean I don't
even know how this how this happens no
it's it's beautiful
see that's what I heard it sounds like a
person almost right kinda I don't know
where it's coming from it maybe it is
someone you ever think of that
maybe it's the crazy guy who lives here
and he's gonna eat out her stomachs well
where is he that man like what is this
made out of
is it yes Wow how is that these did you
see the floating triangle light thing
um yes apart from the triangle this is
honestly the craziest thing in here like
how did it even get in and I mean aside
from some like water damage it's not
really even that junky I know I think
this is all tied to when you tuned it
saw the man
the dog what the crap does that mean a
guy who can't see dogs did you see the
first half see a man about a dog
yeah I don't get it either try your
radio maybe that's like a frequency or
something what
I guess it's locked yeah I already tried
Alex just look I think you tuned in the
triangle when we were outside so let's
see what else happens if you tweak the
dials
is this are you is this you are you
doing this
yeah
I can't even but what is what
I know I know
[Music]
Jonah's hello this is insane are you who
are you on that um yeah sure
leave possible
[Applause]
oxen fress first oxen
I'm frezz e oxen I free Alex Alex
[Music]
Alex are you okay Laura I'm I'm fine
God you sure I'm as sure as I think I'm
gonna be look I'm just gonna cut to the
whatever like I don't know exactly what
happened back there but the sign says
that's an old communications tower and I
don't know about you but I want to climb
that ladder call somebody and get the
hell back home as fast as possible I
don't want to be the party pooper here
but the part no I'm Way ahead of you
there's got to be some kind of emergency
station or way to get out without taking
a fare oh and not for nothing I'm fine
with a little D pantsing or whatever if
the weather's right for it but Hardin
tower oh it's called that I think
because is the radio man who watched it
he was major Richard Hardin the guy's
name was major dick Hardin yeah it
almost makes the whole trip worth it
doesn't it I wouldn't go that far
[Music]
I can see the cave but not Ren or
anybody what do you think happened to
them they're just being laid I can hear
in now let's go to the fort and throw
rocks at walls great it's locked
let me try it
Oh after you oh why thank you
well if you want to do things the easy
way sure
I love this [ __ ]
warning do not use a board ship unsafe
radiation limits you know I'd normally
find this stuff kind of interesting
really
you know normally thanks I guess
is um is anyone there
[Applause]
it's um dad did you get anyone
I don't think so
friends should be off now great but um
don't take offence Jesus
hello Alex
rim oh Jesus hopping crate thank fishing
him I you guys went into that hole and a
bunch of stuff I have no idea what
happened I just woke up like 15 minutes
ago
hi I saw the light on in the tower thing
hey did you know that it's named after
some guy named dick Harden how are you
calling us phones don't work here it's a
code written on this list here but it's
not a normal phone I can't call out I'm
at the weigh station or whatever in the
woods it's been like like just the worst
thing ever just good are you alright
like physically alright because I know
mentally no I'm not alright
I mean do I sound alright or do I sound
not alright I probably sound not all
right right wait I think that's the
other line maybe it's like a night
watchman or some friend someone's
calling on the other line
just hold on in a minute I'm gonna see
who it is okay but make it quick
seriously hello-o - that's great - Alex
why are you answering it this it says
it's gonna mergency mine where are you
right now
Larissa and Jonas is with you of course
he is rough night huh yeah
rough night it's look I'm at Fort Miller
and I don't know why it's like I'm
blackout drunk or something but I'm
trying to call somebody but I'm in a
room with radio stuff I can the peasant
can contact kameena but I don't I have
no idea how to make it work can you just
come over here and figure this out with
me I don't care if you guys want to do
sure we'll be over there in a minute
okay just hurry okay there's like I
don't know I'm hearing stuff outside
fort Milner looked huge than the map do
you know where that
and it dies wait Ren are you still there
[Music]
yeah I guess that'd be too easy
you told Clarissa we're coming so want a
truck over to Milner first see about
that radio
I mean Clarissa can be a handful but
gotta take the bitter with the sweet
yeah if we can connect to the mainland
and get somebody over here we should do
it as soon as we can
my thoughts exactly okay so right there
help Clarissa right our rescuing duties
have officially commenced let's get this
done and get off this rock like the
badasses we are yeah righteous righteous
too
right just
we need a chicken and a chicken I got
world
different telecommunication functions
including point to pulling from its
receivers microwave from its dish
Kabam for satellite reception and
military air band for nearby aircraft
unique in its construction on the tower
houses its office in a segmented
platform directly underneath
[Music]
Jonah's you better [ __ ] run faster
[ __ ] it
okay
get the [ __ ] out of here that is what we
are gonna do as people in human beings
hey Bojinka double bond oh how are you
doing I'm fine I guess
why just checking you know okay how are
you good
thanks for asking but I feel like you're
only asking because I asked you what is
that gonna do one here me anybody
Arisa damn it is this thing working if
anybody can hear me I'm at court Milner
in the I think crap I think in the damp
or something well she's around here
somewhere
I was worried honestly that she might
have left she sounded it sort of scared
like in dire straits actual trouble
right now scared look I think we can all
be included in whatever definition of
trouble there is so Wren said something
about for being decommissioned right but
and hear me out what if it isn't what if
they just said it was decommissioned
nope decommissioned since 1974 didn't
have any use for a billion-dollar
defender of Willamette Valley go Frank
it's like it's not locked there's like
something blocking it
she wouldn't have barricaded herself
inside right what do you think keep
looking I think she's here really I mean
the door could be blocked by anything it
could have been blocked before she even
got here right I don't know I just I
just have a hunch about this one oh you
mean the only door we've checked all
right okay let's find a way in I guess
okay so we gotta go this way
do not enter without permission of the
installation commander whatever you say
sign
whatever you say son
with my blue hair you know what I'm
saying baby you know what I'm saying
[Music]
[Music]
yeah we're here for it's just a giant
waste of time
that light some reason it reminds me of
the cave dinnertime
it's never too late to make dessert not
anymore what the hell is this do you
want to play a game all right I know the
answers no but we kind of do have to
find Clarissa so let's just ignore the
question and thank you
but no business
oh no funny business kind of a girl you
know my name is like Alex I'm cool let's
just do this
where's that [ __ ] oh no no no no don't
be locked come on
Wow we didn't really need to go back
anyway right unless there's no way out
then yes we might have well
clarissa got in through some other doors
so we should be fine
hypothetically speaking speaking of
which she dated Michael is that right
yes quite annoyingly I mean was he the
type of guy that would go for that
like sort of thing I'm just trying to
well you know you'd have to ask him what
he was into I guess I mean just from
what I've heard of him like that one
story about the cops just straight
buying him a beer ah
can you imagine sleeping here I'm trying
not to but why would the construction
guys leave the bed frames seems kind of
kind of morbid let's just find that girl
and get out of here but what do you
think Mike saw in Clarissa really other
than I guess the obvious look Jonas
girls go for [ __ ] and guys go for
hey that's don't just leave me here
Jonas wait Jonas why do you always run
off first it's not a race
[Music]
Jonah's let me in I'm not in the malaria
[ __ ]
thank you gotta go back upstairs
testing testing okay I can't I can't
hear anything outside at all but luckily
this radio thing's working
look whatever so it's it's not in here
and it's just a room so like riddle me
that first of all and then second of all
I take it out the door open like a
second ago can't you are you sure you're
just not turning the knob the right way
or I can't hear anything outside at all
but
hello are you look is someone there
when the time comes what Joe has talked
to his mom what is this what is this
what does this mean who who are you
okay what just happened
cuz that that sucked oh here's a padlock
code 3 for 18
it's not a list of huh they call codes
cookies is that slang or something I
don't know but we got the combo so great
hey did I did did you see that
in in the night anything the reflection
was weird
no I missed it what happened the it was
like our reflections I don't know it
wasn't normal
I'm gonna take a picture see if the
flash
okay make it snappy get it I'm choosing
not to get it
[Music]
three for 18 and what maybe maybe it
wasn't anything I'm just gonna pretend
it didn't happen I say let's just carry
on oh I'm gonna hate to go out in that
so actually before we press on I've had
to go pee for like a while now so since
we're stuck oh my god go in the corner
then Clarissa okay that was definitely
her what is she is this just like a game
to her or something
Clarissa come back we came to help you
don't going out or wait I can I can hear
myself the handprints are a macabre
touch do you know who did that please
tell me it's like a known thing
teenagers here do or something I really
highly no idea well you really couldn't
high in the Cascade Mountains of
Washington the Navy opens the world's
largest radio transmitter it's 1 million
watts can flash a message around the
world in a tenth of a second hey kids
want to play a game
what is it doing hangman be sharp and
listen mister
this is going to tell the classification
board a lot about what can be expected
of you in the future how many questions
will you be able to get in the allotted
time like a test hey why are we being
tested what did we do are you saying
here's a simple one to start so don't
hold your breath
what is the name of this school you are
standing it Sten we're standing in is
nine like a classroom fort Milner right
I mean our friends are finding this tone
[Music]
no no you're I don't know what you are I
don't know what you want out of this
what is going on I feel like I'm stuck
on a tilt-a-whirl
just keep the pointer on the button
question 2 what did the communications
officers at Fort Milner call nobody
calls it called codes cookies no you're
cooking coded radio transmitters have an
important job and you wouldn't want them
to be unqualified no I mean like any job
right
like anything right
[Applause]